this fit is everything tell me what
inspired it um my man edwin um he puts
all my fists together you know this is
botega love otaga it's great um stylist
he's just amazing man love him and he
really just put it together really well
you turned out for your boy angus who's
right here behind you today it's been a
minute yeah so it's been a minute since
you've seen him yeah how does it feel to
reunite here tonight it feels really
good
euphoria reunion yeah
[Music]
i think it's really special to see the
two of you together
congratulations on your honor tonight
how does it feel to be honored and how
does it feel to have this kind of
support bro i mean like
any anything we do bro we support each
other
you feel me but yeah it's a blessing
like
you feel me like young hollywood that's
crazy like
i never would have thought i would have
been in this position so it's a real
you're both so talented and you know
that the number one question at the top
of our brains is euphoria season three
is ash dead and if he is how do you
think fez is gonna move on from
is that an is that a no
okay what do you think
i do think ash is dead you know i'm not
positive but most likely yeah you know
i've been working on a lot of other
things recently and um i i as much as i
loved you for you i moved on you know it
was totally fair listen to me i did this
i killed this
you heard me
not you
i love you brother
you just turned 16. did you get your
driver's license i didn't get it yet
okay look i got a crazy sword i failed
my permit test okay two times okay when
i was 15 i didn't study at all and
i was filming something in between that
and canada so it took a while
but um i'm getting i'm getting my
driver's license um november november
now november okay yeah lucky i'm sure to
driving yourself to set and whatnot
you know your fans adore you and i think
we'd love to just kind of play a little
quick rapid fire game your nickname is
wanna okay so i want to play a quick
game called wanna watch okay
so
wanna one's favorite way to spend a
night out i go to the grove a lot of the
favorite meal
man i like just pastas just in general
yeah what is your favorite quality in a
romantic partner i think what's
attractive is when
i don't know i feel like i see a lot of
like unhealthy relationships and people
just like mean to each other you know
and i did just just peace and happiness
and dream role or next thing you want to
tackle or do i'd love to play robin i
would absolutely love to play robin and
when i get a little older i'd love to
play the joker i just love psychotic
roles just in general i mean you're
dressing for the part you're absolutely
aggressive
i mean have you been in talks is this a
thing not yet not yet
yeah we're working on it what would you
want to bring to a joker role or or a
robin roll and look there's there's a
lot of amazing jokers and there's been a
lot of amazing robin so it's going to be
hard to top them but i'm just really
going to hone in on that do my research
it'd be the hardest challenge yet
it'd be a tough challenge but i just do
you think euphoria prepared you for all
that
menacing behavior i think so yeah
euphoria definitely helped me with that